en scène demain le film sur la route de
madison qui est réunie à un duo
inattendu clint eastwood meryl streep
pour une fois le dur se fait tendre
ce film est une histoire d'amour
passionnée une rencontre entre deux
stars meryl streep en personne nous
raconte cette rencontre nous l'avons
nous rencontrer chez elle dans le
massachussetts nicole cornu donc ici je
me sens chez moi
je me sens moi-même à los angeles je ne
sais pas qui je suis ici j'ai
l'impression d'être vraiment mérité
c'est donc meryl streep que nous sommes
allés rencontrer de bon matin à
stockbridge dans le massachussetts tout
près de l'endroit où elle a choisi de
vivre avec son mari sculpteur et ses
quatre enfants
un paysage qui ressemble étonnamment à
celui de madison county où vit la femme
qu'elle interprète francesca assez
francesca c'est un personnage très
complexe à jouer un personnage qui
s'éveille au cours du film elle ne se
consacrer qu'à elle même et à sa famille
en balisant le réseau était limitée par
la vie qu'elle avait mené jusqu alors et
puis harry van gaal qui lui fait prendre
conscience qu'il existe une infinité de
possibilités dans la vie je pense que
c'est une magnifique histoire comme un
côtes
il ya quelque chose de vrai qui
cherchent à s'exprimer à savoir que
l'être humain n'abandonne jamais un rêve
francesca et sensuelle mais elle est
très réservé le public est lent et ses
mains sur ses joues cache bien sa
sexualité
monde
mais c'est le milieu de sa vie et tout à
coup on pourrait presque entendre son
corps chanter l'annoncé qu'il est pour
beaucoup
d'habitude quand vous voyez un film la
musique a été composée après mes cliques
en fait al avance une idée très claire
de type de musique qu'ils voulaient
j'avais de lui l'idée de quelqu'un de
très distant sans concession
inaccessible et l'accès à ce moment que
j'ai rencontrés étaient presque tout le
contraire de cela ils étaient peut-être
distance et inaccessibles
mais pour ce film il avait sans doute
décidé de révéler d'autres aspects de sa
personnalité et vous aimeriez tourner
avec un réalisateur français
si le réalisateur est très enthousiaste
moi je sais ce que je dois faire
losail puis je parle sont quelques mots
en français
pardonnez moi pour ma pauvre français